حسنًا ، لم يتبق وقت طويل حتى
تصويت جولة الإعادة الحاسمة يوم الأحد ، يمكنك أن ترى
ورائي أن الحملات الانتخابية لم
تتوقف ، فلدينا تجمع معارضة من حزب الشعب الجمهوري
دعماً
لمرشح المعارضة كامال كليش
وعبر الجانب الآخر من  في الشارع ،
نظمت مسيرة أخرى لدعم
الرئيس الحالي راجاباتايب
أردوغان وحزبه من حزب
العدالة والتنمية.  توجه إلى صناديق الاقتراع يوم
الأحد ولكن هناك تركيز حقيقي على
الحصول على هذا الدعم الإضافي في
الجولة الأخيرة من التصويت ، رأينا حزب العدالة والتنمية
يخرج بـ 49.5 من الأصوات
أقل بقليل من عتبة 50 زائد واحد في المائة
لإعلان النصر  في هذه الأثناء ،
خرج تحالف المعارضة بأقل من
45 عامًا بقليل ، لكنه لا يزال
غذاءًا مهمًا ، فهذه هي المرة الأولى التي
نشاهد فيها المعارضة ويتحدون
بهذه الطريقة ، فهذه خطوة كبيرة
للمعارضة بالطبع ، ستكون الخسارة أيضًا
بمثابة ضربة كبيرة.  لهذا التحالف
ولكن هناك أيضًا تحديات كبيرة تنتظر
الرئيس أردوغان ، فلديه
انتقاد كبير لسياساته الاقتصادية ،
فهذا بلد يواجه
أزمة غلاء معيشية حادة ، ارتفاع
التضخم وضعف الليرة ، وبالطبع
لا يمكننا أن ننسى ما بعد البيع في
فبراير المدمر
قدم رئيس الزلزال أردوغان بعض
التعهدات الكبيرة جدًا لإعادة بناء
المناطق المتضررة في الجنوب الشرقي ، وبالتالي
هناك بالطبع بعض الوعود المهمة التي
يحتاج إلى الوفاء بها ولكن كل الأنظار ستكون
على تأمين تلك الأصوات الإضافية يوم الأحد
من أجل إعلان النصر و
لتعيين الرئيس التركي القادم ،
كان أردوغان يأمل في
فترة ولاية أخرى بعد أن أمضى أكثر من
عقدين في السلطة دون بشير سي إن إن
اسطنبول.